bomben wolke hat eine architektur eine
temporäre sie dauert etwa acht mal
die form einer jeden wolke ist
einzigartig jede hat ihren eigenen
fingerabdruck
sich an der einzigartigkeit einer bomben
wolk orientieren um die begebenheiten
eines kriegerischen tathergangs präzis
ein forensisch genau in den örtlichen
und zeitlichen zusammenhang zu setzen
das ist nur eine der methoden mit der
das team aus architekten designern
filmemachern und informatikern vorgeht
um kriegsverbrechen und
menschenrechtsverletzungen im urbanen
raum aufzudecken
die meisten konflikte heutzutage finden
ihn steht in einem sehr komplexen hofer
mit vielen zivilisten mit beteiligung
von medien und um die konflikte zu
verstehen wir brauchen wir neue
werkzeuge der israelische architekt
aerial weidmann hat die unabhängige
forschungsgruppe 2011 zusammengestellt
sie gründet in seiner jahrzehntelangen
arbeit als menschenrechtsaktivistin
palästina forensik architecture
verstehen sich als ermittler
sie fokussieren auf die gewalt die an
ihn und ungebeugt verübt wurde
das scheint kompliziert ist im kern aber
simpel darstellen was passiert ist
kohärenz und verständlich die geschichte
eines geschehnis es nach erzählen und so
juristische beweise liefern für
verbrechen an der menschheit für die
minuziöse rekonstruktion von tatorten
und her gängen verwendet das team
satelliten aufnahmen metadaten und vor
allem bilder aus sozialer medien
aufnahmen von zivilisten vor ort betten
sie in 3d visualisierungen ein und
setzten sie in zusammenhang
wenn jemand unter lebensgefahr ein video
aufzeichnet und es im internet
veröffentlicht müssen wir dies wie eine
flaschenpost parabeln einen hilferuf
dieser geworfen wurde
dass jemand sie aussieht genau
hinschauen ein leitprinzip architekt
oder auch wie im fall des berüchtigten
syrischen foltergefängnisses seit naja
hinhören
gemeinsam mit amnesty international
haben sie eine virtuelle ansicht dass
von der öffentlichkeit abgeschirmten
militärgefängnisses rekonstruiert allein
aufgrund der zeugenaussagen von
überleben die wahl in dunkelheit und
erzwungener stille in haft gehalten nur
aufgrund ihrer akustischen erinnerungen
aussagen konnten
[Musik]
türenschlagen echo räume schritte auf
dem gang mit hilfe von akustikern wurden
die räume architektonisch nachempfunden
[Musik]
entstanden sind albtraumhafte
darstellungen die versuchen die
haftbedingungen fassbar zu machen dem
unrecht ein gesicht geben
es erstaunt nicht dass die investigative
vorgehensweise von forensic architecture
auch scharfe kritik provoziert wenn wir
kritisiert werden von azad kreml oder
den israelischen autoritäten
das ist immer mit der gleichen sprache
gemacht wir seien nicht qualifiziert er
politisches wissenschaftlich oder
manchmal sind wir einfach künstler
nichts davon ist wirklich korrekt das
kollektiv interessiert nicht die
definition
sie präsentieren ihre fälle vor gericht
aber auch in museen für sie eine art
alternativer gerichtssaal
was zählt ist gehört und gesehen werden
sich einmischen in aktuelle vorfälle
das teilprojekt forensische
ozeanographie kümmert sich
ausschließlich um menschenrechtsvergehen
im mittelmeerraum
zum beispiel wenn eine europäische ngo
während einer rettungsaktion eines
kentern des flüchtlingsbootes von der
libyschen küstenwache behindert wird
mit verheerenden folgen auch hier wieder
analysieren forensik oceanography die
dramatischen szenen akribisch werten
schiffsverkehrs daten funksignale
satelliten bilder und filmmaterial
ausbilden das ereignis nach und liefern
beweismaterial für juristisches vorgehen
[Musik]
ich habe meine sensibilität nie verloren
wenn du gleichgültig first für das hast
du siehst du bist du kein guter
ermittler mehr reinigung der designer
als investigators im dienste der ärmsten
und der opfer
[Musik]
es ist sehr sehr wichtig dass wir diesen
scharfen reagieren auf das was er sehen
verantwortung übernehmen das ist eine
bestimmte form leidende menschen zu
beruhigen